okay welcome everyone this is the
meeting of the cabinet of Northeast
Derbyshire District Council it's
Thursday the 22nd of December uh with me
in the chambers cancer Jeremy Kenyon and
councilor Karen
well there's just a bit of feedback
Martin
[Music]
if you just yeah can you mute yourself
or
brilliant
thanks for that
um yeah this is the meeting the north
established District Council cabinet uh
within the chambers cancer uh Jeremy
Kenyon and councilor Karen renick and
then the managing director Lee hickin
and the monitoring office uh Sarah
Sternberg and on the screen I think we
have Lisa Ingram and Martin Derbyshire
doing the uh the governance for the
meeting
um so it's a short agenda uh very brief
uh meeting fortunately uh first item is
apologies for absence I think we've
received apologies from councilor Powell
councilor Q pit and councilor Foster
yeah I think cancer cupert is trying to
meet make the meeting but she's stuck on
the a61 oh right okay all right well
there we go then
um any decorations of interest from
anyone
no uh minutes the last meeting I'll
happily move them as a true and accurate
record
seconded by Cancer renick all those in
favor
okay that's carried uh and then the next
item then is item four which is the
Northeast Derbyshire District Council
climate change strategy refresh and I'll
hand over to councilor Kenyan for this
one yes thank you chair
um yeah sorry to drag everybody in for I
think it's a one item agenda we've got
it might be a second one snuck on there
since but um thank you for coming in uh
the reason wanting wanting to get it
done now rather than the next one is
that
um there's a an organization that
assesses councils uh climate plans and
we want to make sure they've got the new
one to work on not the one from 2019. uh
that said this strategy is built on the
back of the previous one uh it was
already a good strategy and it's
basically extended it the main thing is
to include more of the original side of
things even though technically
it's
housing is obviously a big thing so
that's you know embedded in there now uh
We've also separated out the action list
that used to be included in the previous
strategy because of the action list is
huge it's ever evolving and you know
having it in the strategy just
which was
uh We've also taken an approaching
strategy of not just focusing on our own
emissions we look at the bigger picture
and we've got a lot of influence in
various parts of Northeast Derbyshire
especially our seven thousand dollar
households that live in Council housing
so for example ewi
um technically uh not something that
will affect our own measured of
emissions but it will affect thousands
of residents so it's obviously key that
that's in there and the same planning
policy is another one of a similar ilk
for our direct missions we've been
working on everything from vehicle
efficiency to Leisure Center heating
systems for example at eckington pool
the recent decarbonization work looks to
have reduced this is early numbers
subject to change but it looks to reduce
the gas use by around 70 already and
that's before we've even got the whole
system up and running and uh
um the Asos heat pumps will be coming in
January I think or Beyond in January uh
one more thing to make you aware of is
that our Baseline emissions have changed
for two major reasons
um so it makes comparisons with previous
years difficult one was bringing the red
bin collection in-house and that's
reflected obviously in a lot more diesel
consumption with a doubling of the uh
the vehicle movements basically and the
other was taking on Kilim isolation
Center
um you know Leisure centers are
notoriously energy hungry and adding a
fourth one in is uh
it doesn't change the overall picture
for Northeast but it means our things
are under our particular remit the show
arise
um
and of course Carey's made it really
hard to evaluate the last few years
and one more thing just to note in case
we get asked about it it's also worth
noting some councils have quite a low
footprint because they've basically
outsourced everything
so they've outsourced Leisure and Bin
collections for example in some councils
and others don't have any Council
housing as well and
um maintaining seven thousand Council
houses is itself a huge amount of Fleet
and infrastructure to do that
so
um the strategy is is going to evolve
over time the action list in particular
will evolve over time
um
and
um and that's it really so there's only
one recommendation in the report which
is to access
uh
Kenyan very happy second is really good
document uh really uh comprehensive and
and uh really good that we brought up to
up to sort of speed in terms of where we
are now given that it's well it's is it
the full four years three years since
the last one uh it was introduced yeah
through now so a lot has changed in that
time so it's really good to see it
brought up to date and uh uh you know
sort of reinvigorating that focus on on
how we're addressing our impact on
climate change so yeah thanks very much
for this over to you again uh casser
running
yeah thank you I just want to say a huge
thanks to Kenyan and officers
um from when we first set up the climate
change Action Group
um because we've done a lot of work it
is uh I think we all accept Pluto pays
principle in this in this in this
Council and in this room and we know
there's there's cost to that and it's
been it's taken a long time to try and
work through this list and we we weren't
shy of attacking some of the the bigger
submitters in the first instance and
congratulations to the team I'm
particularly proud of the external wall
insulation uh through our um through our
housing provider rignaled and some of
the work we've done there not only is it
a great amount of saving of carbon but
so residents tell me the 300 pounds plus
the saving in there any bills and you
know bearing in mind of the energy
crisis at the moment that's been a
hugely welcome and uh I'm really pleased
that governments are putting out these
grants The Lads grants and the hugs
grants that will hopefully also help
private individuals and we're gonna
we're just put in a large um bid some
more of that fundings fingers crossed I
think we've delivered really well we're
on the biggest uh um external wall
installation
um uh schemes in the country so we ought
to be massively proud of that and um
also um in terms of
in terms of the uh waste hierarchy
and there's the environment tax actually
is going to make some differences in the
in in the new year just waiting for more
detail on that and but you have to
remember we are picking up the in terms
of hierarchy in terms of prevent you
know reuse
um before you recycle we we only come in
really at that that's that sort of
second point so it's really more about
now how we can improve the prevention
and
prevent the waste in the first place and
we do know that um the government's
extended to produce responsibility will
make a big difference in there to help
us all make better choices but on the
whole I'm really pleased to be able to
support this and thank you officers and
uh all the work they've done to try and
uh achieve this
thanks very much yeah absolutely Echo uh
Echo all those sentiments there
um if there's no further comments from
anyone we'll move to the uh all those in
favor
okay that's carried thank you very much
uh the next item is any urgent items of
which there are none uh and then I'll
move uh to exclude the public uh so I
move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business
to avoid them the disclosure of exempt
information it has to find in part one
schedule 12a Local Government Act 1972.
if we can just turn off the live feed
Martin